[Music]
I'm going to be showing you how to cook
the best Christmas lunch that you and
your family have ever had we're going to
be cooking the perfect Christmas starter
smoked salmon with a fresh and delicious
fennel and apple salad an roast turkey
with herb butter a decadent Chestnut
pistachio and Sage stuffing topped off
with a rich apple and cherry gravy and
all the trimmings mouthwatering spice
honey glaz carrots and parsnips brussels
sprouts with bacon and chili perfect
goose fat roast potatoes and fantastic
bacon wrapped cocktail sausages and to
finish it off a terrific Christmas
trifle this is for everyone you don't
need to be a brilliant cook but a little
bit of preparation ation will make all
the difference so get ready cuz I'm
going to be telling you my top tips and
sharing those all important Trade
Secrets how to buy the best turkey nice
meat and bird how to get more bang for
your buck cheapest chips and everything
you need to buy for the big
day stick with me and you'll be ready
for anything when the stuffing hits the
fan on Christmas
Day
first things first the turkey now it
wouldn't be a proper Christmas dinner
without a big fat turkey always go for
the best meat that you can afford and
remember the more mature the bird the
better it tastes so get a turkey that's
lived a
little if we want to keep our local
butchers on the High Street we have to
use them my grandfather was a butcher
and as a chef I know how important they
are when it comes to buying Quality Meat
is that okay yeah LD gates in West
London has been thriv for 150 years and
is's one of the most respected butchers
in the country Danny lidgate is the
fifth generation of his family to work
there so he knows what matters when it
comes to buying a turkey the golden
rules of buying a Christmas turkey
really make sure you get to a good
Bookshop make sure you know the history
of the turkey if you're buying from a
supermarket it's best to avoid the
frozen turkey it's going to take ages to
Thor out it loots loads of liquid when
you defrost it you're never going to get
the same quality in succulents as you
buy a nice fresh bird
what you want to look for really is
avoiding a bird with bruising with torn
skin you can see a lovely fresh bird
here it's got no markings the Skin's
intact nice meaty
Birds a defeating fewer people try and
buy a whole bird the smallest one
possible this bird here would be great
for a family of three or four people
you're going to get the St meats and the
lovely breast Meats if you were to buy a
crown of the big one you're only going
to get the white meat it still gives you
the whole bird of f as well so you still
get to Christmas dinner carving a
[Music]
bird next to make sure that Christmas
dinner is special you must buy fresh
herbs and stock up on those essential
spices for my perfect Christmas dinner
you're going to need star Andes cinnamon
sticks chili and vanilla you'll need
chives for the starter parsley and
taragan and time for the herb butter to
go with a turkey and sage in the
stuffing and they've got to be fresh
that's what makes the difference between
a dinner that's just okay and one that
will blow your socks
off spice boy Stevie par is an
award-winning 26-year-old Chef who runs
the dock Kitchen restaurant in London's
Notting
Hill Stevie has traveled the world in
search of the best herbs and spices so
he knows exactly what to look for when
it comes to buying the best for my
cookalong menu
staran is a beautiful spice but it's
very strong in flavor and we use it on
pork or on Duck it has a flavor that
almost cuts through the sort of
greasiness of some of the
meats what you need to look for when
when you're buying it is that you're
buying whole star that are not all
broken and Dusty and that will be an
indication that the star is quite fresh
when a recipe calls for chili flakes
what I tend to use is these little chili
flakes here which are actually Turkish
moist and oily and not too hot so you
can use quite a good quantity it's
almost like a coarse kind of smoked
paprika you can use them almost like you
use black pepper as another
seasoning cinnamon is the one that
everyone Associates with Christmas and
what you're looking for when you're
buying cinnamon is soft sticks like this
that you can crumble in your hand I
think there's no real Point buying
powdered cinnamon it hasn't got that
same kind of flavor it's it's been
ground a long long time ago and it's
lost that amazing Vibrance that you get
when you just break a cinnamon
[Music]
stick I think in general these days
there is basically no excuse for using
guide her especially a herb like parsley
which is kind of you know it just tastes
like old cut grass the smell is really
really unpleasant you're better off
buying a beautiful big fresh Hardy bunch
of parsley a bunch of parsley like this
from an ethnic shop can cost you less
than a pound whereas the miserable um
sort of floppy thing that you get from a
supermarket it could be two quid
the important thing to remember when
you're cooking with herbs or spices is
to be confident pack them up and throw
them in things use quite a lot of spices
and just really enjoy cooking with herbs
and spices so that at Christmas when you
want everything to taste really
fantastic you've got all these brilliant
things to sort of ju up your
[Music]
cooking back to the bird to make sure
your turkey is the tastiest juiciest and
the most succulent bird you've ever had
I'm going to be talking you through a
herb butter this is something you can do
in advance the night before you'll need
butter flat leaf parsley Thyme and
taragan chop the herbs and beat them
into the butter and don't forget to take
the butter out of the fridge first thing
in the morning so it's nice and soft
when you want to use
it now I'm not going all Hue ferny wory
on you but when it comes to vegetables
for my cooking I demand the best and so
should you it's Christmas and you want
this to be a meal to remember so go
local get your veg from a green grosser
nearby if you can if not Supermarket
stuff is fine you just need to know what
to look
for rushon is one of Britain's busiest
green Grocers he's been in the trade for
26 years and supplies some of the
country's best restaurants and most
demanding chefs including
me so he definitely knows his onions
when it comes to buying your Christmas
veg important thing about your Christmas
veg is keep it as seasonal as you can so
you're looking to buy things like
Sprouts pars carrots all fantastic
seasonal veg Pack full of flavor really
inexpensive cheap as chips your roast is
Maris Piper really good potato if you
can buy them loose you can look at them
you can feel them make sure there's no
blemishes on them trust me they'll come
up beautifully nice and crisp on the
outside fluffy on the
inside when you get your Sprouts there's
nothing difficult these regular Sprouts
here nice and green the most important
thing is make sure bottom is nice and
clean and white if you see it's brown it
means that they've been trimmed several
days ago and they're getting old you
don't want that you want them nice and
fresh tender sweet lovely tasting
vegetable carrots for your Christmas
dinner again another really inexpensive
veg get something that's not too big
like these medium to small size carrots
nice and sweet this time of year lots of
flavor these big boys here we know in
the trade as donkey carrots for your
Christmas lunch it's a no no they're a
little bit too hard Woody and they won't
be very sweet because they're an old
carrot another great winter veg the pnip
don't get large ones just like your
carrots they do have a woody core
through the center and if they're
smaller there'll be less wood inside
them so the rule is use your eyes let
your eyes be your guide make sure your
veggie is nice and fresh don't get
anything that's too big and old you
don't need prepackaged goods go and buy
it Loose Christmas Day the biggest lunch
of the year make sure you enjoy it
if you're cooking along with me you
don't have to prep anything in advance
I'll be taking you through it step by
step so if you want to go commando
that's not a problem but if you have a
chance then prepping your veg is a great
way to get ahead and it will leave you
more time to enjoy the morning with your
family to prep my luxurious spiced honey
glaz carrots and parsnips peel and
quarter the carrots and Par Snips and
make sure they're roughly the same size
put them on a a tray and cover them with
a damp
cloth prepping the sprouts with bacon
and chili is easy even easier if you buy
your Sprouts ready trimmed don't bother
crisscrossing them just cut them in half
right through the core that way the
Sprouts Stay Together put them in a bowl
and cover them with cim
film and last but not least to get your
spuds ready to make the perfect goose
fat roast potatoes simply peel them and
quarter them stick them in a bowl of
water cover and put them in the fridge
and remember you can do this the night
before or first thing Christmas
morning another great way to grab
yourself an extra half an hour in bed is
to make the stuffing the night
[Music]
before roughly chop your chestnuts and
add to the sausage meat do the same with
the apricots and pistachios next Bunch
the fresh Sage leaves together chop and
add to the Bowl finally add an egg to
hold it together and give it a good mix
put the mixture into a loaf tin and
really push it into the corners cover it
with cim film and leave it in the fridge
until you're
[Music]
ready don't worry if you haven't got the
time to prep anything before the big day
just preheat your oven to 220° and drag
a TV into the
[Music]
kitchen I'll be there to help you
through the cooking step by step making
sure you have a happy and a delicious
Christmas keep calm and carry on
[Music]
cooking good morning happy Christmas is
your re on at 220° good let's
go
[Music]
welcome to Christmas cookalong live
can't believe we're doing this thanks
for joining me on this very very special
day and we're at home now the whole
country is cooking along up in
Manchester we've got Max Beasley hello
Max happy Christmas Merry Christmas
Garden how are you absolutely
Sensational great to be here on this
lovely day now it's a little bit colder
than La um who you cooking for today
well here we have my father hi God love
to see you how are you sir and and just
over here he's great just over here my
ma Joanie my uncle Roger hi Joanie Uncle
Howard Roger and lovely lovely sister
Katie Howard Katie good to see it Max
what on Earth has happened to your
arms well I know that you've got a bit
of an obsession with beex and I feel
like the Love Has Gone from me so uh
I've gone out got myself tatted up so I
can get embraced with you a little bit
more looks like you got carried away
with a felt
tip
lovely now are you feeling confident
about today yeah I'm really excited
actually some of the uh ingredients look
great I'm looking forward to uh trying
the gravy out which looks Sensational
and uh I'm really raring to go good good
good good now over to two people who
know the only way to cook a perfect
Christmas lunch is to cook with me arent
Lydia happy Christmas
chist Merry
Christmas now really good to see you H
welcome all three of you I'm not too
sure if you can hear me properly but AJ
how do you rate your cooking out of a
scale of 1 to
10 um you know what golden I've never
really cooked much in me life I've done
a bacon sandwich now and then but I'm a
quick learner and I'm excited I'm going
to give it my own I think you're going
to be quietly impressed listen good luck
with the cooking I'll come back to you
later on Merry Christmas to all of you
and good luck cheers mate merry Chistmas
right first things first we're going to
make the most amazing herb butter for
the turkey okay that's very easy but it
guarantees your bird won't be a dry one
now soft butter first thing we're going
to chop the parsley and the Tagan now
this is so important okay Bunch up the
tagon and the parsley don't worry about
chopping it too finely because you want
all that flavor coming out over the
turkey parsley in taragan in now a
little bit of salt and
[Music]
pepper who Merry Christmas Christmas how
are you Hy good to see you my darling
welcome come in and I brought you a
little present with little glitter Birds
oh it's very kind thank you come through
thank you thank just in time to get
started on the turkey fantastic please
going take your coat how are you both
I'm I'm htic how are you how are you
Mary hofus good to see you yes thank you
thank you sir now darling how are you
yeah I'm good thank you yes good good
good are you well uh I'm hungry you
hungry I'm hungry are you ready I'm
ready I'm hungry I'm not a good cook
cook but I'm hungry okay great so right
let's go through to the kitchen darling
we're going to catch up with you later
gorgeous dress yes gorgeous dress good
to see you all right thank you all right
bye uh wow wow wow okay I'm ready now
good to see you come good to see you man
yeah cheers good to see you good to see
brother hey the Hof is in the house
everybody come on Merry Christmas Hof
the Herald Angels singing good to see
you good to see you you good your
girlfriend is gorgeous I know I know
she's from Wales you have had a
fantastic year haven't you yes how could
I not an amazing judge br's Got Talent
yeah yeah hando yeah I'm doing um Hof
the hook the hook and we're breaking all
the records in Bristol at the Hippodrome
and I'm staying in town we're going on
tour okay great um I saw a show called
an audience with okay yes and we just
kind of took that format and we're doing
an evening with BR David Hasselhoff and
we go we start in February good luck a
normal Christmas day for you would be
what would you be sunning it in
California would you be down in ciff on
Christmas yeah yeah you'd be doing yeah
would you be with your family right yeah
have you got the Welsh accent yet um k i
I don't know the Welsh science is like
reading in Chinese you it is difficult
isn't it very weird they're the nicest
people in the world you know what that
means though yeah no no you don't know
wreath yeah Long Live whels exactly good
to see you both now how is he at cooking
not very good not very good stop we're
going to find out now right you're going
to help me okay so all right give that
butter a little mix okay in there we've
got some taragan okay okay and we got
some parsley uh I'd like you to take
some time what are we making so we're
going to make some really nice herb
butter for the turkey herb herb not herb
now pick off the time herb got the time
why do you always say it without the
herb H use a h or h no you never use a h
do you no h h h the H so in there butter
okay parsley targan and some fresh thyme
now this is going to go into the turkey
Under the Skin okay now the secret here
is to go in from behind don't look so
nerv wait a second I saw that
once family sh 10 in the morning shower
now the secret okay yes is to put that
butter between the skin okay and this is
the hard bite you've got the easy bit
okay now just remove the skin very
carefully now this is for me the secret
that keeps the bird really nice and
moist okay the skin is released from the
breast I want you very carefully to take
half the butter put on the left hand
side and the other half on the right
hand side on on on the breast inside
inside wao now I I've never done who
don't look so scar as only butter there
you go wa hello imagine imagine Merry
Christmas imagine you're giving Simon
Cal a quick massage no no let's not go
there spread that nice and even okay
nice and even up the other side on the
other side whoa this is very weird I
suppose being American it's almost like
putting a a sort of baseball glove on
your hands yeah it is a big one better
up well done okay now right underneath
okay okay good good good W you've done
this before no I've never stuck my hand
in a turkey so to
speak thank you good good good very nice
very sweet okay now give give your hands
a little wash I'll put it on the tray
all right from there a little drizzle of
olive oil okay really important got the
butter underneath the skin that's going
to get the breast nice and moist but you
want that skin nice and crispy so okay
all right trust me the Butter's
perfectly positioned if the Huff can do
it anyone can do it let me tell you salt
pepper now turkeys in the tray most
important part also is the gravy so I'm
going to start off with some water into
the tray and you'll understand shortly
whil it's so important to put that in
good cool now will we put that into the
oven sprad over there thank you okay
which one top shelf one there we are
this one no no WR one there we go this
okay excellent okay good man now that's
in for 220 for 10 minutes and then we'll
get it nice and brown we'll turn it down
to 180 good okay great this is better
than Hell's Kitchen so
now this okay that's that's magic that's
in the oven we can relax a little bit
now we're going to make the stuffing
okay um how's your chopping oh good good
that's is that sharp uh it is sharp a
little bit so be careful please right
chop the apricots yeah thank you I'll
chop the chestnuts okay this is the
stuffing P this okay okay now good I see
you got a little suf there so little
Sushi nice and co ah I got to be careful
smaller straight in is it smaller than
that that's it no it's lovely okay okay
well that is don't take all day we're
cooking this Christmas not next
Christmas now right apricots in
chestnut's in pistachio is in I'm going
to season that with some fresh Sage okay
now well done well done well done well
done straight in all right add a little
bit of salt and pepper my God good well
done my God you're incredibly fast
unbelievable now one egg that's going to
bind it together only one egg only one
egg okay one egg one do you want mix
that around now you continue chopping
I'll mix it around now okay
good now apricots in you can push them
straight in good man excellent could be
good now haly when was the last time he
actually cooked for you the last
romantic meal yeah beans and eggs beans
and eggs yeah excellent good now stuff's
done okay now the secret here to get
that in to the tin incredible so turkeyy
in wow and the stuff in this is the
stuffing this is the stuffing so it's a
nice sort of pork Savory sausage meat
now apricots chestnuts and sing that
looks great okay good now wow good okay
there we go leave that behind so far so
good now turkey is in the oven stuffing
is ready if you're falling behind here's
a little ketchup for the ultimate roast
turkey and stuffing remember take
softened butter chop parsley tagant and
Thyme and
mix season and massage Under the
Skin pour on some olive oil season and
add water to the tray to give the turkey
a lovely Rich crispy brown skin put it
in the oven at 220° for 10 minutes then
spoon over the juices to make sure the
meat stays
succulent cover and roast at
180 for the luxurious stuffing chop
apricots chestnuts pistachios and sage
and mix into the sausage meat
Stone and
egg and roast roast turkey with herb
butter and
stuffing
perfect good job right Max up in
Manchester how's your stuffing I'm very
very together and calm and obviously
here we have the
stuffing have you got the foil on the
turkey that's the
question getting the foil on the turkey
right now
Commander unbelievable I'm in the right
house unbeliev you're definitely in the
right house okay great we'll be back in
a minute
[Music]
crazy right welcome back I'm here with
the Hof he's in a good mood the tug is
in the OV and my house smells absolutely
fantastic I hope yours does too now it's
time to make our delicious starter smoke
Salon Parcels with a fennel an apple
salad big smoked salmon lover I love
smoke salmon okay we've got the nation
tweeting about your hands haven't been
cleaned properly clean my hands
properly clean they look good now right
follow me okay take a little espresso
cup yes okay now this is just a little
sort of little bit of magic okay so take
your smoked salmon yeah and place it
into the bottom of the cup and leave the
sort of almost like the little edges
hanging over the side okay the secret is
to line the espresso cup with the smoked
salmon wow okay just like that lining
lining lining yes lining right now mhm
what's going to happen we're going to
make a little smoke salmon mousse okay
Max Arch keep up with us now please the
rest everybody else in the country keep
up too push them down okay so it's
almost like a little sort of almost like
a little sort of butter cup okay now
while you do that that's lovely nice I
got my cream cheese here all right okay
I'm going to add a nice tablespoon of
horseradish that will zest it up
okay some creem fresh that will give it
the tartness as well for inside the
smoked salmon a little touch of pepper
and a smidgen of salt because the smoked
salmon is naturally season God this is
great salt okay M I want to eat this
that's good I've never seen you work so
far all right okay now chop up a couple
of pieces of salmon okay and add that to
the bowl that gives a nice little bit of
texture inside that mousse now from
there into the bowl and then grate a
little bit of lemon zest so it's nice
and fragrance oh man okay awesome so
we're going to mix that up and then just
very quickly chop up some chives now
that's going to give it sort of almost
like a little sort of oniony flavor can
you mix that for me please David thank
you
um are you a big foodie do you enjoy
yeah yeah this I want to take a lesson
and learn how to do this this is great
favorite foods or what what do you enjoy
eating I love I love smoked salmon I
love turkey I love steak I love I love I
love pasta nice what yeah what uh what
don't you eat um I'm not a big coconut
fan really yeah that's a trust me
there's no coconut today okay good
excellent all right great have you got a
big Medallion under there there that's
the microphone I was okay he' been
pumping out in the gym well well no work
out good man right from there put that
in your hand all right okay um I want
you to spoon that in okay all right 's a
spoon now get the back of the spoon okay
and push it down in a way that sort of
almost fills up that cup we want to be
awesome oh my God going awesome now can
you still fit into those bayw watch
shorts Yeah well yeah I can still fit
into them yeah I still run in slow
motion yeah I have a walker outside
though now Haley only being 27 can you
remember Bay Watch
a little bit a little bit yeah her first
question was uh who do you play on bayw
watch I said you're perfect for
me right fold over those little flap and
then with the palm of your hand just
push that down like that you going to
make it this thing disappear what not
yet he's coming Dynamo is arriving
shortly now just push that in there and
that's going to set in the fridge nicely
Wow's another awesome yeah okay s that
up again yeah nice good good good good
okay now the secret about these they set
in the fridge okay literally 60 Minutes
in the fridge they will set and Max how
you going on with these little
Parcels getting on really well mate
actually they're all they're all
prepared
obviously and now I'm putting some
salmon bits into the uh masap Pony and
all the all the all the gear here over
here uh Max don't start drinking yet
please yeah okay
good now okay wrap them over okay push
them down so they set really nice okay
AR how you doing he looks lost doesn't
he I'm all right mate he being very
stress you know what Debbie's helping me
out but I don't know how you do it you
don't know how I do it I'm getting
nervous about Debbie I'm getting all
panick it's all about Debbie you're
absolutely right AR come on wakey wakey
okay now please put your kettle on and
during the ads I want you to peel your
peirs and to chop the Sprouts like this
there's the core put the core on the
board and slice them in half that way
they stay together
[Music]
now lots of you text in and worried
about the actual cooking time for the
turkey please don't worry it's on
average 30 minutes per kilo and then at
the end if you can let it rest for 45
minutes minimum to now even better but
rest assure I'm with you every step of
the way okay now time to make the most
amazing dessert it is the perfect
alternative to a traditional Christmas
pudding now if you'd like you can do
both trifle trifle excited yes very very
good good good now would you whip up the
cream for me please yes okay is this
Trad never whipped cream before it's a
traditional English dessert Haley you
know what trifle you grew up with tries
right you love tries good now um
grenadine in okay have you ever tasted a
tri before no never okay I think I may
have but um now gas on okay water into
the pan we're going to melt the
chocolate now the most important thing
is here we're going to make it like it's
called a little B Marie okay break up
the chocolate so we can melt that
quickly okay wk's doing well is this
whipped okay good now you do it
underwater oh excuse
me Merry Christmas come in how are my Dy
good to see you welcome to the mad house
thank you for the hot really just seen
his car
out that take you back uh yeah great
take that c from you you look gorgeous
are you well thanks I am good to see you
come on in please please please stay
down good to see you hey hey dude nice
to be here don't leave me here let me
introduce you to the Hof hi is how are
you how are most amazing lady Christmas
nice meet meet you met
your Have You Seen My Big Fat Gypsy
Wedding oh yes I have it's great extra
this lady makes all the dresses
fantastic show fantastic all right you
enjoy it h yes yes I'm I'm I'm whipped
up I I'm whipped up I trust that there's
no uh sort of gypsy weddings on
Christmas day right h no not CH day
that's the only day there we are that's
for you oh thank you mer Chas so much
thank you good to see you Lely um you
going to help me with the trifle I'd
love too would you be so kind just to
cut some of these pears okay slice the
pears and put them into there please
into the Grenadine
[Music]
excellent now our turkey is in the oven
our smok salmon Parcels are chilling in
in the fridge and our delicious dessert
is halfway there um Max and arj are you
basting your
turkeys I've been basting the turkey uh
I've made a mistake with the uh the the
cream on the trifle is uh split I've
done too much of that on it oh no come
on you've over Whipped Your cream come
on you've turned it into butter now it's
Christmas Day
Max all those CES look like
love I know I should have gone to your
school boom
can you give your dad a glass to drink
that wine looks like he's swigging from
the
bottle yeah do you want a glass for that
wine very Good's
it are you still doing all the work you
know what golden I was stressing out
earlier I was really panicking but now
I've had a little drink I'm relaxing I'm
really getting into the swing of things
now baby golden he is useless mom is
doing everything for him I'm actually
doing everything when you're not on
camera he doesn't actually do anything
and then he goes like that when he back
on camera Debbie did you give him that
jumper for Christmas D can't hit me what
a shame no actually dided
this I can't believe that jump has been
knitted uh Lydia what did he get you for
Christmas I'm I going to give James the
Christmas um a kiss that'll be
enough it's a family show come on oh
he's kissing the
Mother-in-law God bless him right time
to make the custard okay for the triy um
FMA be so kind please to separate the
eggs I need the egg yolks in there okay
um cream so egg yolks into diet you put
the white in there oh you can wash your
hands thank you d uh now this is very
special okay this is a uh a fresh
vanilla pod we're going to cut that in
half okay now the secret here is just to
take out all those vanilla seeds
Okay do not get tips from half how to
wash his hands please okay he's already
been told off this morning on Twitter
now vanilla in okay get that cream shall
I show quickly yeah come on so you get
the egg like that crack it over your
hands okay and then separate the yolk
like that six in there please darling
thank you
good come on don't look so scared it's
only an egg cream in can you give that
little whis please yeah got the Freshman
little smell of that that is amazing I
mean incredible wao what is
that now what's the largest dress you've
ever made them what is it um the one the
heaviest yeah 24 Stone 24 Stone yeah how
does somebody walk wearing that they
don't they don't she had wheelies on you
know them little train with with wheels
in the bottom a dress that had wheelies
on well a had wheelies on and she had
the dress on that is extraordinary 24
Stone and I mean what color was it it's
white they're always white they're
always white so they never go for sort
of cream pink Navy no always white
they've got to be white are we
put
s thank you very much don't you like my
shirt not really no I'm sorry about that
do you ever have that moment when you
think my goodness me they don't like the
dress I better get out of here I fear
for my safety um I always have that
feeling before they come that what if
they don't like it but they always touch
was up to now they always have I I I
trust they'd pay in cash sometimes
stereotype isn't it now sometimes theay
sometimes bank transfer um the whole
documentary was a huge hit right yeah
and it was just a sort of a great
insight for the nation to see they live
because it was you know it was
extraordinary why do you think it was so
successful I think it's because
everybody cuz they're so secretive
nobody knows nothing about them and it
was just like a little insight into
their world I found the dating scenario
fascinating when a guy likes a girl they
grab somebody yeah ever been grabbed no
ever been grabbed you often often does
Patty ever grab you no no never Patty's
lovely pad's lovely right give that a
little mix
you got the strong one of you in shape
trust me uh good cream's coming to the B
got the Villar in there it's going to
infuse it eggs corn flour that helps to
thicken the custom okay I'm going to put
a little bit of cream in there first
okay please continue whisking okay okay
good man now um so traditional Christmas
would be turkey turkey yeah all the
trimmings all the trimmings yeah uh
large family yeah I've got four kids and
all their Partners as well they all call
wow wow wow wow unbelievable half
traditional Christmas view would be wor
in La typical Christmas for me yeah what
would you be doing no boo no boo no no
no I would be my family would be turkey
and stuffing cranberry and mashed
potatoes and uh my mother made a special
dish with green beans with cheese
covered in corn flakes you know kind of
like a rotten it's fantastic it started
off nice but then you put cornflakes on
top it's fantastic seriously yes yes
unfortunately she's not here to help but
um and I can't cook but uh unbelievable
really good and corn flakes on top of
green beans and it tastes good yes very
good wow favorite that was great and
Pano's going well this year Pano's going
great we're breaking all box office
records there's still tickets off the
hook the hook and shout out to all my
panto cast they are unbelievable people
and we're in Bristol till January 8th um
fantastic now that custard thickened up
okay that awesome you can see just give
that little whisk now
that needs to set now and get really
nice and cool and it smells really nice
and fragrant light unbelievable
incredible now I'm going to put that in
the fridge okay to get nice cool that's
awesome uh now what happed on this we'll
use that for later there's someone else
I'd like to talk to cuz this is a very
special moment yes it's Christmas Day
and we've got our very own Christmas
cookalong baby born earlier this morning
please pass me the tablet thank you um
right Jennifer um first of all Merry
Christmas congratulations to you and
Stuarts and I believe you had an early
Christmas present at 1:28 a.m. the this
morning yeah that's it and how much does
he weigh £8 4 oz wow what a Whopper
congratulations um have you decided on
the name Gordon sounds great
James we've gone for Jack Patrick Andrew
weather wow Jack Patrick
Andrew wooden incredible and not even a
little Gordon slipped in the middle as a
second name
no incredible Maybe will think about it
uh
amazing um now had you not given birth
um early this morning at 12 128 would
you be cooking along
Jenny I would yeah definitely uh you
look amazing yeah me um and Stuart a
very proud dad and a new stunning baby
Jack um I've got a little present for
you there as
well yeah I've got it
here
look
now I was born on Christmas Day born to
cook along
um enjoy the Cook Off Jenny shirt and
Jack congratulations merry Merry
Christmas wow how fantastic our cook
long Christmas baby lovely amazing right
I will see you in a minute
amazing
welcome back merry Merry Christmas to
you all hope you having a great day so
far now excuse
me nighty old turkey good to see you you
well welcome I'm really good are you
well I'm I'm absolutely fantastic have
you having a good one already we're
having a crazy one this morning yeah
yeah hosing over whipping the cream and
uh I got that text from you last night
saying could I come and help please
please please please what want me to do
um we're going to do some little pigs in
blanket little chipas how are you what
they're called I'm good you're great I'm
feeling great last time I saw you was
many many moons ago in London now you
look thinner right and I've lost about
11 Stones since I last saw you lost my
stone you've lost my weight really
that's incredible really I mean
absolutely you look fantastic you what a
year youve had I you know the best year
in that Flavia say love which camera are
you on say could you say something in
Italian toia it B Bal
b c I love you why AR you
here so rumor has it you're the new anwi
no that was the past rumor stop it could
anwi
do couldn't do that at the way you move
when you came out that Cannon honestly I
peed my pants I mean that was
extraordinary did it hurt no no but
you're doing what you did to your pants
didn't hurt me me um I came out that
Cannon although I was lying on like a
little tea tray in fact what I laid on
was as big as that everyone and then it
sort of flew through Wembley like that
to that great number and then I had to
zoom off I need some help I need some
help I need some help yes right time to
make some pigs in blanket okay there
delicious right you didn't name this
after me now come on come on what do I
do right take your restro bacon get your
little chipata okay and roll it nice and
tight okay there you go now this is a
bit like me on coming out the cannon
isn't it sort of same shape come on you
look great
uh these are delicious little more you
want more than
one right see guess over there look
hello Darlings how are you oh there L
felma Jack Meg H Matilda over at the
Hipp drone Bristol having fun he's
packing them in he's packing the sold
out show um now are you still dancing I
am still dancing I just love it I mean
you know when I when I a couple of years
ago G and I decided to go back to
Showbiz cuz that's my roots musical
theater and I'd always wanted to do
strictly but I was too fat I was
bordering on 27 Stone seriously and um I
decided a couple of years back to lose
the weight go back to what I think in
life what you tend to do is you do too
much of what other people want you to do
and not enough of what you want to do
yeah and so I went back to Showbiz did
some fantastic wonderful uh performances
I went up to ad an eightborn theater in
scarra um did a a great show there um
then locally in North Wales oh yeah n CL
BL now Welsh now we've gone from
Italian Clen BL now I can't speak Welsh
but but I did that and I did a mid
summer night stream in North Wales and
then strictly called and I tell you the
best thing ever it not just wonders
personally in terms of losing weight but
it did bring you back from the brink in
a way that it shot you out but yeah but
it brought me back doing something I
love to do astrology was only over a
hobby Gordon it was never meant to be my
job yeah where this but didn't you find
it was a romantic thing to do didn't you
think it was a it's just I mean all that
wonderful music I mean all the pro
dancers I mean you know I've had a text
this morning from Alona who of course
went on and won it and um I she just I'm
I'm just so happy I thought you going to
dress up in a gold Christmas know where
is where is it well that's up in Milton
keing cuz I'm doing panto there but I
finished last night but I'm going back
for three nights and in pan who you
playing who's your uh your I'm playing
Genie at the camp oh sorry the lamp and
um and then flab and I are going to be
leading the New Year's Day Parade
through London oh wow and I think I'm in
that gold suit that's amazing the Hof's
the Hof's here as well he's in panto
he's behind
you
I'm taking pictures of everyone taking
pictures okay now the most important
part is to get some color on those
sausages are these all your babies put
them in the oven 100° for 25 minutes
okay in a couple of minutes we're going
to make a fennel and apple salad to go
with our delicious smoked salmon Parcels
okay so whil the ads are on you need to
slice your fennel really thinly three
fingers one in front two behind cut the
fennel bulb in half and just let the
knife do the work up and down okay Arch
I hope you're paying attention wakey
wakey look no thank goodness Debbie's
there come on arj we're always paying
attention arj slice your fennel please
we pay
attention I've done it already mate
we're ahead of you we're ahead of you
already sliced I don't think you has
sliced it okay great be careful when
slicing see you in a
[Music]
minute right welcome back now it's time
to get the stuffing in the oven this
house smells delicious H how you doing
I'm doing fine I was just looking in the
in in the refrigerator looking in the
refrigerator right was doing anything
okay the drinks on the table you don't
need to go in the fridge those are his
drinks sort of out okay now we're going
to finish off our delicious christas St
okay your fenel should be sliced so it
should be nice and crisp as well add
some Capers into the fennel okay Russell
come and help me please sir yeah I know
you love getting in the kitchen put the
phone down and come help me wants me to
tell everyone about his
tour what is I want you to pick some
know where you
know would you pick some parsley and put
it in there for me please thank
you Rosemary what do I do to put some R
my dish here gold okay you're here Joy
to the world that's for you that box
you're here to cook not to tweet come on
very very clean hands everyone I watched
them right so we're going to dress the
salad okay little bit Olive all salt
pepper okay and a little zest okay of
lemon okay A little zest zest oh now
from there Fab okay now I love this
smell now that's fine then give a little
mix up and then from there I'm going to
take the Apple do you want the STS uh no
just the
nice Christmas to see you come in
are gorgeous come in come in come in how
are have you seen the Hops car out there
we have indeed very nice does that take
you back uh yes it does yeah good to see
you both come in come in come in thank
you thank you very much um is Christmas
a big day for you INF yeah yeah very
much brilant brilant
brilant you just passing Max everybody
Max the house everybody passing Mary
Christmas baby how you doing bab all
right
brother pleas that with my no no no i'
got some I've got some experts here now
oh yeah expt
passing in house with the there you go
we're in time to start grating Snow
White Apple how are you both let would
like a drink um yes CH champagne champag
CH Megan two nice last champagne please
thank right so you be just hold that
other side there like that okay and give
that a little gra okay no worries watch
your fingers please of course okay now
who normally does the cooking Christmas
Day I'm going to be honest I cook
serious yeah seriously so it's the man
right yeah thank you yeah um and how
romantic is he around Christmas he's
very romantic is he really Ser
especially this year and I've been
following you both on Twitter
congratulations you just got engaged yes
we have yeah please keep your hands off
my
trifle yeah I don't want to been it was
it a traditional proposal did you get
down on one knee he doesn't have to come
on come on come on come on come on come
on um yeah show the it was lovely um
it's a little bit big so there's a bit
of cot tape you got cot tape on there as
well yeah you had to show that smile
smile SM turn around did it come as a
surprise did he sort of catch you
um
no no I mean we I kind of mentioned it
uh um a few a hinting a bit Yeah and
then uh it just got to that kind of that
magical moment where it had to happen so
the documentary was amazing 7 Absolut
loved yeah um why do you think the
nation fell in love with it because it's
real you know and it's kind of real
emotion real it's educational as well
you know and and what was it like all
being together in that house I mean
nightmare was it a nightmare no we had a
great laugh wicked wicked yeah really
good I'll do the other one no you put
that in there okay me and you in
particular didn't we because we didn't
know how we were going to be you know
living together for seven weeks cuz we
don't actually live together and um it
worked out for the better so good
and Max you paid the dwarf grumbly is he
grumbly in real life does he have his
moments no seriously I'm more gring
seriously he's a pussycat right
yeah he lovely but what I loved about
you more than anything you're almost
like that sort of alpha male you sort of
standing there not taking it from
anybody like almost like a mini Gordon
yeah you know it has to be done and you
know are you like that all the time or
it just depends on what company you're
in no no no no you know in it's a way of
life isn't it you know I've had to kind
of grow up dealing with kind of certain
things so you learn to kind of that was
the deal with fascinating thing about
the documentary in terms of what it
showed how good it was and the message
it got out there do you still get grief
no no no no it's I tell you the
documentry has been nothing but a
positive um you know you get people Max
and Car Max Karen you know know our
names and stuff instead of like oh look
at those two people okay now we met one
of Britain's youngest people this
morning morning baby Jack 128 this
morning let's talk to Britain's oldest
man
sir Reverend re Dean first of all Merry
Christmas you are 109 years old
extraordinary Merry Christmas
sir and Merry Christmas to you g amazing
and thank you so much for joining us and
I know um I mean you are just
extraordinary you've survived two world
wars you've seen 24 prime ministers um
my question to you is how many turkeys
you
eaten well I've been a vegetarian nearly
years isn't many I so you're telling me
Reverend that the secret to a long life
is being a
vegetarian
yes I'm in trouble straight
away uh sir what does Christmas mean to
you mean to me the coming of Jesus
Christ into the world with a message
MH extraordinary now we have a very
talented researcher uh Matt um he's on
my team and he's up there cooking along
with you Matt good to see you that's
your grandson are you proud of him yes
I'm very proud of him he's very good to
me and I like him very much brilliant uh
congratulations are you looking forward
to his smoke salmon
Parcels you're
what are you looking forward to the
starter yes brilliant um 24 prime
ministers have come and gone do you have
a
favorite yes anony m m wow okay great
well listen H best wishes enjoy lunch
and um have a very very happy Christmas
thank
you extra
[Music]
unbelievable you enjoying then right
welcome back now it's time to take the
foil off the turkey now the most
important part take that off okay and
just get that back in there to get
really nice and crispy that is looking
good absolutely delicious now time to
serve these delicious little chipas come
we give them out now yeah I'm sure
hungry at home so pass these along Tilly
we do the honors take one and pass them
along please my Dary nice crispy you got
them good don't drop them Jack lady
first
please sorry sorry sorry you know I'm
lady little femin all us the hey these
are the ones we made ear and they're
fabulous good good um
AR are they enjoying the
[Applause]
[Music]
chipas is a lot more than a they look
fantastic but have you have you forgot
put the bacon
on oh my goodness M mine a bit loose but
there
[Applause]
Sal Dynamo hey Merry Christmas Merry
Christmas welcome thanks for having me
good to see you uh thanks for dressing
up are you
good are you well it's it's like a shirt
it's like a shirt and a sort of festive
nice and you fancy little piging blanket
why not yeah um everyone D is in the
house are you good I'm very good before
we start actually I want there's a
present for you but I don't want you to
open it yet okay to save it later on
yeah okay but keep it somewhere safe
feels like a jumper I'll put it over
there um are you a uh big fan of pigs
and blanket I like pigs in blanket we do
it please this right here yeah uh right
you're going to show us a little uh
Christmas uh little Christmas trick
manate yeah let's start off um I'm going
to put my P blanket now yeah good yeah
yeah definitely right let me try
something can you get me an empty bottle
An Empty Bottle like a sort of just a
small bottle yeah little
my okay come around guys this is can
I also H come over Hy come over now I've
got a coin here Che a coin yes is that
make sure oh you want to excuse me right
so the bottle let's try this m come
there go perfect there nice just hold
your hand up hold on to the bottle tight
yeah hold on to the bottle on the end
yeah yes where's the coin again right
here and you just emptied that bottle
didn't you yes watch
this wow wow wow wow incredible
incredible how'd you get it out yeah I
was smash it
well done uh you've had the most amazing
year haven't you it's been pretty good
you've walked on water I've been piging
blankets M's house at Christmas sorry I
could be own I'm coming later amazing
now Granddad was a big influence for you
right he means a lot to you and he was
the man that sort of got you out there
yeah he got me into magic um kind of to
get out of a bit of trouble with some
bullies mhm they were putting me in a
wheelie be thr me down a hill MH every
day after school and he showed me a way
to take away that terrible and um I've
actually got Grandpa titled on my neck
so he's always watching over my shoulder
wow bless him and that made a big
difference in terms of what you did to
sort of show them a trick that got them
the bullies on your side and almost you
sort of disappeared out of that scene I
think I scared him a little bit what did
you show I'm not a big guy particularly
but you know they were bit scared um
should we try it on you on me Jack do
you mind okay okay so just um I Travis
you know you're I'm much bigger now and
you're a lot bigger than the bullies
were but we'll try anyway so just I want
you to take your hands like this and
just on and just lift me up I don't wear
that
much so you can lift me right yes not
that difficult no I want you to get
ready to lift me yeah yeah so put your
hands you're not going to need me in The
Goonies no no okay right just look at me
yes just lift me again I should feel
[Laughter]
heavier and
[Music]
scary
now the Hof's got a pin on welcome back
okay now it's time to glaze your
stuffing with some apricot jam and then
put it put it back got the T ban in the
kitchen and then put it back in the oven
now uh I would like you please Russ you
said your two favorite ladies yes I
thought it was your three daughters
they're seriously upset you know what
I'm having the best Christmas morning
for a long time I love this man he's
gorgeous I love this
man I love everybody what am I going to
do unbelievable don't ever hug a man
with a knife uh a little delay of jam
must remember that when I leave the
house yeah okay great right what am I
doing now uh you I'm ready you okay you
ready ready okay couple of tablespoons
of bapy cot jam on top of theing yes two
tablespoons and then back in the pleas
minutes says FL where are you on there
she wants to
wait right okay veg um take the other
side oh okay now from there nice down
good just an angle see you've used n
lots of times good well done in half
I'll do the past nips okay okay great de
Russell not the whole jar just a couple
of tablespoons please it smells amazing
in here unbelievable that's me good now
Russell please be so kind to put it back
into the oven so it glaze that's enough
no that's
enough too much uh Dynamo a little bit
of Christmas magic for us yeah I we got
couple minutes all right let's do this
watch your fingers this is looking
lovely wow out anyone anyone you want
show everybody you focus on the carrots
focus on
the everybody everybody everyone seen it
every see it yep yep you seen it focus
on I'll take it got it yeah can I use
this top yes yeah I'm afraid this I'm
put it
about halfway down watch this you
idea
oh my
goodness wow wow wow wow uh who taught
you that one Grandad that's just me
that's just you unbelievable we cut
yourself no no no no wrapped up to wash
your hand again we are getting into so
much trouble tweeting Across the Nation
please wash your hands I'm sorry call
dynamo magician uh Dynamo let's be
honest you're more like sort of David
blae than Paul Daniels right I'm more
like dynamore more like who was your big
inspiration growing up um it was my
grandpa to totally honest like he was
the only kind of real magical role model
that I looked up to um over the years
I've seen all the greats like you know I
was with David Copperfield in Vegas
recently pen andella Legends you know
David Blain amazing you know I'm just a
big fan of magic in general incredible
have you got another miracle plan for
next year I've got a few things that I'm
working on mhm I'm pretty sure you'll uh
definitely get to see
him trying to make okay now it's time to
get your delicious turkey out of the
oven now well done so far we have taken
a huge weit okay off your shoulders now
turn the oven back up to 220 you'll need
that for the potatoes but look at that
that is amazing now how long that uh
we've got some very exciting news uh
we've got another
baby Ryan Marshall would like to
congratulate his friend Brett Harvey on
becoming a father this morning unbel
believeable blind me one born every
Christmas Minute fantastic news right
now turkey out okay the secret here Lorn
we're going to get a lot of Capricorns
out there tilt that that looks painful
tilt the turkey out you want those
roasting juices I'll explain now why um
there we go wow now Max can I have a
look at your turkey
please what does that
mean Max what are you doing sitting down
come on we're live live
show me your turkey Max oh here we
go no you're going to okay no a show me
your turkey
please that's my turkey that's my turkey
look at our
turkey that looks much much better than
I
expected um and the good news is the
turkey's got a real tan not a fake6 tan
well
done okay okay right the turkey's
resting okay so trust me you guys have
done brilliantly well now we're going to
make the gravy and you know there's no
point having a delicious moist turkey
unless you got an amazing gravy so just
tilt gravy tilt sing tilt the fat from
the tray okay and just tilt it from side
to side you'll get all the fat coming up
the top and all those juices will sink
to the Bottom now from there put the
tray okay on okay to the hob now get a
little whisk halfway give that a little
whisk for me please I'm just going to
nip those little wings off here there
he's at it the at it again okay tell us
about your excellent thank you give that
a little whisk nice now brilliant um
could you jack could you put the
potatoes in please Kettle in okay and
put the potatoes into the pan good man
salt and off we go good man right give
that little whisk excellent well done
turn the gas on a little bit of salt
well done Jack now give that a good
scrape this is where it's really
important to make a perfect gravy couple
tablespoons of apple juice okay apple
juice apple juice in nice it's got all
the little trimmings from the turkey got
the little bits of wings okay from there
Christmas would not be Christmas without
Sherry touch a Sherry in there okay nice
this nice nice nice turn that gas up
absolutely now to thicken the gravy
that's the bit everyone sort of panics
about okay we going to take a little
knob of butter and some
flour okay now from there just give that
a little mix bring it together almost we
call it a sort of beret but basically
it's flour Touch of salt okay and mix
that up nice now Dynamo Jibber cook um
when I get a chance I'm I'm not the best
cook he doesn't have to just magic set
up I'm I'm pretty amazing with a
microwave I'm not going to lie seriously
what kind of food you love eating what
what's what's your favorite my grandma's
cor beef fashion a big yorra pudding oh
really yeah it's the best and you're
that size how do you keep that size
eating food like that corn beef hash in
a York pudding HP Sauce Big York pudding
yeah HP Sauce HP Sauce go with
everything nice nice nice nice touch
you're doing a good job there half right
little bit more of a wing in there I
want to sort of use these little bits
that makes the gravy absolutely
delicious now from there little touch of
chicken stock M it smells incredible
right abely ja put the little lid on
there bring up to the ball yes now
that's good this my favorite BR I like
to eat an amazing night rider now cook
cook off incredible right give that a
nice whisk and from there okay the bman
in now this thickens the gravy okay and
see what happens it stops it from going
lumpy but more importantly the flavor uh
Jack you pass those spoons behind please
have a little taste create the
seasoning than
but and for me the gravy is as important
of the turkey thanks bud put them down
me jump in half what do you think
Russell have a little taste please H
please jump in here we go right here we
go Damo have a little taste my Christmas
magic M now oh my God I tell you what it
is very isn't that lovely amazing
amazing
nice isn't it good right is it as good
as that has okay my grand good nice nice
nice okay
[Music]
good ol hell Merry Christmas how are you
sir you're wel
yeah welcome it's the Ry household this
is it not a long way from Chelsea for
you what was over the river man it was
over the river come on nice jumping by
the way thank you much what you
expecting a little bit ol's in the house
everybody meet you man are you
good hello sweee now we've got a
beautiful blue sky yeah 160° outside you
got a jump on Well's on where have you
been where have I been oh I came down
from Southampton today it's colder down
there it's more Seaside good A little
muddy uh a little bit muddy a little bit
muddy yeah good good good uh early
Christmas present this morning uh it was
it was actually it wasn't but I did um I
it's my favorite jumper and I got a
couple of Christmases ago and it have a
squeaker go on yeah so which is my
favorite thing of it so um I'm happy to
are you upset wearing that jumper upset
well you used to go out with Philip
Green's daughter so you could be in
Barbados right now sat on the beach
could be I'm I'm happy that I'm here
with you you're happy amazing amazing
amazing amazing right we're going to
make some stunning roast potatoes okay
they have been part boiling okay so I'm
good at potatoes are you good at
potatoes now just drain them off okay
they've been part boiling literally 6 or
7 minutes and then back onto your board
give them a little Shake yeah okay give
them important bit is this is the
important part okay give a little Shake
tells me about this ah okay good little
seasoning salt and pepper you put some
salt pepper in there for me good thank
you now from there a little touch of
semina that's what's going to get yeah
seina that's what's going to get them
really nice seina and crispy okay
Revelations please don't get any your
hair in my potatoes I I won't I promise
okay right give a little Shake now okay
all right SE is from a plant isn't it
that's right in Thailand in Thailand
that's right um I'm very
impr now kind of foods um you love
eating what is it kind of foods I love
eating I I love English English Foods I
love game game uh fish big Sushi fan a
lot of sushi and game wise game wise bit
of feasant bit of grous um yeah you
shoot um friends of mine do really um
and go into their lovely country houses
and uh they like to kill deers and stuff
right you're actually made in Chelsea
did were you born in Chelsea no I grew
up in Southampton in I did you live in
Chelsea though uh but yes I do I live in
where about uh behind Chelsea Football
Club nice nice nice nice now Now give me
a little
Shake give a little Shake there there
you go okay good do not burn yourself in
the goose so we got gooseb in there so
that's going to make the potatoes
absolutely delicious the semolina is
going to make it really nice and crunchy
you SE them nicely I'll pop them into
the oven what's difference between goose
and duck just a bigger bird like fat
wise fat wise there so much more I mean
so much more fat in the goose than there
is in a duck right they're more for your
money definitely now give them a little
Shake okay and then get them into the
oven make sure that oven's up to
[Music]
220 okay welcome back now it's time to
finish our trifle uh thank you for
washing your hands hasn't been doing
well at all now we're going to slice the
Swiss roll okay the secret behind here
Hoff I need you and some of those
muscles whipping the cream please thank
you um Ollie yes going to slice that
nice and thinly okay okay just down like
that cuz we going to line okay the tri
yeah okay now just watch you don't cut
yourself okay and watch those
Nails Russell crystal ball not crystal
ball I don't use crystal balls you don't
use crystal balls I got crystal balls
and I don't use you don't have crystal
balls Dar what you want me to do I want
you to take the Swit roll and line it
all the way
around are we doing both of them good
yes please thank you um do you cook at
home Ollie do I um I order in a lot but
I go out quite a lot but I do um
yeah cook a little bit I like trying to
make sushi no I I like that's quite
complicated that you know it's quite fun
though yeah it's very fun the second
date uhhuh I love these you know I love
try biggest food disaster Ollie what
would you say biggest food disaster
getting chesa my flatmate to cook ready
really is horrific not you you make
great grab it he could be out disaster
here um show we there I'm
impressed is that good as it yeah I want
you
just to put is that the is that the very
dry one that's it what about that lovely
madira that you can have
is try and line all the way around the
top brilliant is it Sher you put in Tri
Sher I got a bit pissed on the trifle
last
night unbelievable tyly what have you
got on there what is that Santa Claus
Santa Claus come
on good job right you said it done okay
now look at those peirs we drained the
peirs they've been soaking in grenadine
okay hello how you doing 1,000 miles
hour are you just yeah
sure right now we're going to start
assembling the trifle okay yeah start
off with first now that's that c you
made earlier isn't it isn't it that one
with the vanilla that's right fabulous I
love this a couple of tablespoon ature
of that G right some pair in there
please let's do it together all together
yeah just half of those pairs in there
should I put it with my fingers pleas
theyve been washed they've been washed
we're going to do it in LS what you done
with that how have you made them red
we've soaked them in
grenadine very organic aren't they they
are they look delicious now from there
um you want Jer good morning Merry
Christmas good to see you well good to
see you J Ang POS in House's everybody
yeah Che good good good good I white
beard and Christmas good to see you well
done are you well you're not bad thanks
uh training this morning yep now this is
the highest that Tottenham have been
anywhere in that Premier League in 16
years you feeling good feeling good were
you an Arsenal fan yet no no no Chelsea
now uh what's the prediction who's going
to win the league I think we got a
chance yeah we got a chance I think it's
the I think we have a better chance if
you play more Austin TR Tran got inj at
a moment but it should be all right
ready what is it soon just hamstring
grade one yeah but should be fine Are
you seriously training this morning yeah
just in a gym stuff
little now I'm D to ask I'm obsessed
with my kitchen at home but apparently
you have a hairdressing Salon in the
basement of your house is that true you
know you're the second person is that
true little little Barbers I haven't
actually built it yet but that's what
I'm by the way and then we going put the
cream on top there as well that's it no
more biscuits please more biscuits on
there please
okay right okay our starters are made
okay and our dessert is nearly ready
when Russell hopefully hurries up the
turkey resting and the potatoes are
roasting nicely okay let's see how AR is
doing AR how's the
trifle uh it's going all right golden
but my finger's been cut you
cut come on and he's HED C
honestly useless useless come
on it's all gone terribly wrong in I
terribly wrong the custom looks
liquid oh what about this cream here
unbelievable Max mine how you doing mine
yeah doing beautiful I've just got a
lovely bowl of scrambled eggs which is
going on top of the trifle Max all that
money you spent on those cooking courses
you can't make custard Max Beasley come
on oh
God okay
okay it's been a long time since we
spoke we getting
[Music]
there so now it's time to get those
stter served and what you like putting
food on a plate not too bad to be honest
yeah really uh smoke salmon now um kind
of foods what do you enjoy eating I like
salmon to be fair you like salmon yeah
good now two plates I don't want to get
that expensive suit dirty so here's the
tree okay Dynamo is going to work some
magic if it doesn't work for you now
little Shake get your fingers and just
pull down okay and then from there bring
it back out and that's what you want
there I think I've got it beautiful
beautiful huh nice well done you've done
this before haven't you bad my mom's a
chef so I'm under a little bit of
pressure okay we got to do it right
everyone's waiting for us in the dining
room good well done you have done this
before one on each plate
please excellent now from there okay
take a little bit of your fenel salad
okay yeah um are you good cook seriously
do you enjoy cooking I don't mind there
yeah I'm put I'm put what kind of things
do you enjoy cooking basic really like
salmon pasta mhm just the basic stuff
mhm great now uh chances for England to
win the European Cup come on please got
a I've got a chance he got a chance
especially I think with the young
players that's coming through now as
well y now that little birdie told me
this morning okay that you still go home
to your moms for dinner come on J she
bring this to my house she
bring you get your mom to bring your
dinner always every Sunday does she
still do your washing no she doesn't she
she
doesn't okay right let's check in with
arj how are the starters going
down no that one's ruined it's
ruined they are going amazing they are
everyone is loving them uh apart from
argies which are ruined arj what do you
think you've been a food con ofur for
many years and I who best what in your
opinion your professional opinion what
one is better incredible um I think
Lydia's looks more incate you look one
do you prefer uh yes AR first of all I
think I think
Debbie that would even fill up my little
sister uh arj welcome back well done
Lydia keep him going please yes yes uh
Max how's it going to Manchester show me
your
salmon okay big boy he going extremely
well and um obviously you know this lad
here don't you well
that's scary very scary uh Max potatoes
out of the oven it's like having you
with me here baby it's
beautiful potatoes are still um roasting
off okay good make sure they stay nice
and crispy okay great if you're running
behind just turn up the oven get them
really nice and crisp tats uh do you
know what uh you look a little bit scary
Max unbelievable um I'm having him off
I'm not into him
anymore unbelievable he's taking his
tats off I bet Robbie wish he could do
that um is it true you're thinking of
leaving Tottenham no chance no chance no
way yeah is that you're scared to leave
him because of Harry we know what he's
like when he's in a mood scared to GA
he's worse than me it's good mood today
so it was good it was good fantastic
right time to serve yeah let's go
excellent everyone at home servy
starters here we go guys right off haly
ol wowk we are off you go I hope
everybody's enjoying their start as much
as we are uh that for you fantastic I
tell you what the Revelation is G in
this fantastic fenel salad light crisp
oh it's really and for the salad 10 for
the salad 10 smoke salmon smoke salmon
and stuff well about a seven about a
seven thank you ollie what would you
give that good good eight a good eight
thank you I made it it's a
10 why you like what do you like how is
it max out two I'll give it
one
come on come on come on it's Christmas
10 out of 10 definitely brilliant
brilliant okay right um I need some help
with the root veg please okay yeah that
was last time you roasted some veg when
was that oh probably last week actually
Ser some yeah some lovely Welsh lamb
Welsh lamb lovely right nice and high
lamb you know yeah grows well not grows
but the the Sheep are just outside where
I live wow um along the Druid EST near
Port Maran oh wow and it's just the most
beautiful beautiful lamb it's fabulous
brilliant brilliant brilliant brilliant
so veg we're going to roast the pars and
the carrots together okay couple of
tablespoons of olive all carrots in
please be careful there just the carrots
yeah no just TI in that there wash your
hands there you go nice right are they
going to be done in time okay give that
a little Salt and Pepper please Russell
thank you my D thing
ar
ar you're supposed to be doing your veg
now l
come on Arch we're not finished yet dear
oh dear the Christmas lights are on but
Arch is not at home wow around yeah give
it a little wi round okay good nice
right from there little bit of cinnamon
in there okay cinnamon cinnamon
surprises star andise and some nice time
okay so the idea here is to get them
sort of almost fragrant roasted
beautiful smell and then to get them
really caramelized Russell yeah a little
touch of honey fantastic you're full of
surprises young man these flavors are
beautiful I was just trying to think the
fact that you lost 11 stone did you have
to go out and buy a complete new
wardrobe I mean well well no you know
what it's like when you start off slim
you don't throw anything away so you go
up from like a 32 waist and I went up to
about a 56 waist really and I'm now down
to a 40 was incredible so I'm in the
middle of the Wardrobe I mean that is
fantastic honestly and you feel bitter
yeah well I mean the reason I wanted to
do strictly was because I hated the gym
mhm and so dance is a great way of
actually losing weight so I was doing a
lot of disco stuff no you can you can if
I can do it you can do
[Music]
it okay welcome back trust me we are
nearly there the veg are in the oven
make sure that oven's cranked up to 220
Max Beasley Manchester how you
doing
fantastic they sue
you uh seriously you got me worried with
those
tattoos okay oh no I'm not into it mate
I'm not into it now Max you know
Christmas day very festive it's all
about turkeys what's the biggest turkey
you've made um the biggest turkey I've
made probably going on the
FW I mean the movies you've been
in
oh I don't know Tanya the milk
made can I just say Max seriously that
turkey looks stunning
yeah right look at that that is so
succulent it's moist I can't wait to get
involved and just eat it all
up listen Max put the veg in the oven
okay leave the turkey rest in
brilliant
yeah okay great right now Dynamo is
going to show us some Christmas magic
Dynamo come on down
Bud should we get Jack in Jack come
everybody let's go he's a massive fan of
yours you know that huh yeah right so um
before we do this actually I gave you a
present when I first walked in you've
got it somewhere safe right it felt like
a it felt like a sort of um a jumper
keep hold it for right now yeah um let
see I'm going to
take mhm pack of cards can everyone see
that they're different yeah mhm happy
with that happy
Jack just point to
one that one that one right there or do
I don't want us to look it just yet hold
your hand out like
this no one's seeing the card right
right don't sneeze now Jack your dad
gets lots of presents every Christmas
right for me everyone always buys me a
pack of cards yeah is there any presents
that everyone always gets your dad
um aprons aprons yeah use APR everywhere
right I want you to open the present
yeah and you could have had to set any
present there right you said an apron
yeah wow actually got you an Aon wow wow
wow wow it's a special Aon wow what
no no it's got your first and it's got
one card on there yeah no you any card
we haven't seen this card yet right okay
put the open on should i w the
card
unbelievable that was fantastic Merry
Christmas uh Jack were you in on that
were you were you part of that no no
yeah incredible how how how how listen
you give me cooking lessons and we can
talk I'm not going to argue with that
trust
me now if your potatoes are ready take
them out of the oven if not leave them
there for 3 four minutes get really nice
and crispy we have some more babies
being born extraordinary a big
congratulations to S Danny with baby
Logan just been born in Northern Ireland
amazing congratulations Emma and Adam in
Birmingham on their first baby Holly
congratulations Holly May
congratulations to kazah hara's proud
Nana to Hayden in London unbelievable
nowat we're about to make the Brussels
Prouds trust me we're nearly there
you're doing a great job let me tell you
turkeyy resting potatoes are rolling the
stuffing is ready put a frying pan on
get really nice nice and hot we're going
to saute the Sprouts okay you might look
at me like that your kids this is Tilly
they want me to outrival the Christmas
tree hear what she just say your these
are your children you bring them up to
dress me up look I'm sorry I'm like
Barbie to them pan on first a little
touch of salt in there okay now we're
going to part blanch these Sprouts okay
oh
blanch Baby Jane right Sprouts in just
test it okay now from
there okay close here ear ings honestly
chly if you listen if you think this is
watch me on Strictly tonight and you did
you perform better I performed better
yeah I have an explosive entrance
tonight were you were you upset with
that early exit no early I was in there
for 10 weeks 10 weeks ready and if I
hadn't gone out at Wembley then flavier
and I wouldn't have done the Christmas
special tonight seriously so it's worth
it's worth it I went out in the first
round Ser did you really was that
Dancing with the Stars I was happy to go
out in the first round oh were you D but
you've got legs look yeah I know why did
you get a kick out so fast what happened
who knows unbelievable what were you
dancing cha chaa uh yeah no I know no I
don't know yeah it was a cha chaa chaaa
first one hle come on yeah could you
dance with him yeah can
you it looks like wrestling not dancing
potatoes Out the Oven nice and okay he
gave up on me out
now okay from there we doing now lons
okay to the pan the reason here is want
to Rend all that fat stick those spouts
in there AR absolutely yeah Brussel
Brussel Brussel bruss gr right give that
little toss for me there you go nice
good oh nice nice nice good I don't know
what the hell I'm doing a touch of uh
chiny flakes in there please H here
yeah brilliant and some chili flakes
good that's garlic so
good G yeah in and some chili flakes
there on the left hand side there go and
a little just we're going to sort of
Siege it like with gar Just a Touch nice
uh Hoff big fan of Brussels yes yeah not
anymore not not since some um Brussels
yeah the city the the country but Bru
but not not Brussels BR not after that
last competition yeah I'm going to fly
home yeah May the wind behind you always
be your
own um just think at this there's been a
lot of talk okay bayat yeah movie night
Riv movie who would play you who would
be a perfect actor I don't know you know
we're talking about trying to bring
Night Rider back as a film and I would
you have somebody play my son you know
that's like top of my list right now but
could you see Simon Cal playing the
Night Rider any forgotti Baron Michael
you're terrible driver yeah no he
actually Simon Cal would be actually a
really good voice for Kit you know yeah
you kind of the voice that kind of you
know put you down you know type thing in
a cool way yeah and how would that make
you feel a movie of something that was
one of the most watched TV shows
anywhere in the world well I'm trying to
buy the rights to it right now to make
the film so we're pretty close and a
little potential C roll in there yeah
yeah no no I'll probably take the Devon
character it would be Michael n's son
you know we go out we we'll stay true to
the original which have the heart the
humor and the action but you know right
now I'm you know I'm spending most of my
time here and how about Russell with a
small performance in the Baywatch movie
where would he sit you know Russell you
could like you could be like a like an
evil person you know I'm good at evil
yeah you're good at evil yeah
yes Russell can you
swim can you swim doing evil can you
swim doing evil over there can you swim
no you can't swim no I can't swim I
wouldn't I couldn't Dance Before flat so
maybe I could swim well if you in the
Baywatch movie and you were you were
drowning you drown I swim you Dr you
said that Del light on your face the
Garlic's in there to give a little bit
flavor the Chili's in there to bit of
heat really important to get those lad
really nice and crispy now cool russels
we're going to drain them off okay now
here's a secret okay I used to get so
frustrated with Mom putting a crisscross
on the bottom the secret is cut them in
half speeds up the cooking process but
more importantly they stay together give
them a little shake and then add them
into the lad on please in there straight
in please thank you nice lovely VOA Well
Done Right ah genetics how are your
Brussels uh Lidia's taking control of
the Brussels so she's been doing that
all morning she's doing pretty good to
be honest with
you doing pretty well he's doing nothing
I think it's going to be lonely for
someone his Christmas unbelievable uh it
might be me at the moment mate you're
making me well
jail I know golden you will be when you
taste my PPS mate you'll be proper gel
if there's one pip I don't want to taste
is yours let me tell
you you'll be quietly surprised right
Max how are the
veg hey B are okay
mate is it raining in
Manchester it's raining cats and dogs
and lons
boom okay right now right give them a
little toss make sure they're nicely
seasoned take out that garlic okay now
put them into the dish okay stick the
dish in the oven okay
[Music]
welcome back merry Merry Christmas what
an amazing day it's been crazy here and
all those babies born across the country
merry Merry Christmas to you all right
first thing first reheat the gravy okay
now put the gas on bring the gravy up
the bowl just check in the oven can
never do enough checking roast Sprouts
are done beautiful carrots P Snips
roasting stunning right now now
arj how are the Sprouts going yes
sir you tell me mate Sprouts there way
okay we got two pans of sprouts one's
boiling one's soing Lydia what's going
on yeah the ones that this was the ones
that I did okay and James was slow cuz
he's been slow at everything so he's
still on the
boil okay and he potatoes look gon
golden nice lyia this has really taught
me a lot you know seriously I think it's
Tau
more Lydia are you thinking of changing
your mind on the back of his performance
this morning you're not going to marry
him now
surely I definitely am Gordon definitely
not definitely not I think I'm be fing
out the door after the dinner just make
sure he never wears that jumper on that
wedding
day uh arj I know I know look at them
arj now that Mark's gone are you going
to be king of Essex uh well you know if
people want to call me that then they
can call me that I don't want to I'm not
going to give them the name myself but
if people think it then they think it I
don't think found the king of essic
fantastic Max how's that
gravy oh it's um spectacular I'm just
removing some of the uh some of the wing
that I left in there earlier just to
give it a bit of an extra juu and um
it's going to be
great unbelievable Max I heard this
morning that your mom has made backup
dishes in case things go wrong
is that true yeah well she normally
makes 18 dishes yeah she makes 18 dishes
each Christmas and today we were reduced
to your stuff but it is going to be
amazing we are actually tasting
everything and it's great mate how's the
trifle
looking let me just show you that Gordon
bear with me just come this way it looks
like coim Modo what are you doing with
your shoulder up there like
that oh what do you let's just go there
and just get into this area will you
stop puffing your chest out and breathe
please can we just get over here with
the there's the F family you can see now
this is the trifle that Gordon has
arranged obviously and
um feel quite good today actually is it
that way which uh Max what have your
guests thought of the food so far how
did the starter go down
well why don't we ask them guys what did
you think of the starter dad absolutely
fantastic absolutely wonderful
really okay good good good good thanks
to all my guests thanks to arj and Lydia
in Essex and to Max and his family in
Manchester it's been an amazing day
happy New Year goodbye and Merry
Christmas and now it's time to serve
wow
the